malheureusement les vacances sont
terminées mais c'est le moment en tout
cas de faire un premier bilan de
l'activité touristique dans la région
ile de france et pour parler de ce sujet
miquel et demi d'euros bonsoir la
rédaction de tv 78 ce que le bilan est
positif pour la région ile de france
plutôt oui la présidente de la région
ile de france valérie pécresse a annoncé
fin août à paris le bilan touristique
sur le premier semestre la période
estivale dans la région secteur
enregistre et 17,3 millions d'arrivées
hôtelière un chiffre stable par rapport
à l'année dernière une baisse de 3% a
quand même été enregistré en grande
couronne en écoute la présidente de la
région ile de france
nous avions un premier trimestre qui
était inquiétant avec une double
contente les mouvements des gilet jaune
dont les images avaient fait le tour du
monde et par ailleurs le break site deux
handicaps cette année que nous avons
réussi à surmonter que nous avons réussi
à surmonter en ciblant un certain nombre
de pays et de public que nous avons
réussi à attirer à paris alors les
italiens les espagnols les américains
les japonais
et puis les français au total 9 4
millions de français sont venus sur la
région sur cette période
trente mille de plus par rapport à 2018
la clientèle internationale représente
7,9 millions de visiteurs bon michael
j'ai ma petite idée mais quel est le
site qui a attiré le plus dans les
yvelines dans les yvelines à ce n'est
pas une surprise c'est le château de
versailles qui a réalisé les meilleurs
chiffres dans le département 4 millions
de visiteurs sont venus voir le site
une hausse de 6 4% qui place le domaine
juste derrière le louvre mais la
présidente de la région ile de france
pense que le tourisme dans les yvelines
a encore une marge de progression dans
les yvelines on a la possibilité de
développer une offre touristique
colossal autour de toutes nos maisons
des illustres
nous avons un certain nombre de châteaux
aussi qui sont magnifiques je pense à
breteuil je pense à rambouillet je pense
à dampierre je pense à mauves hier on a
toute une série de musées de parc
naturel aussi ce que le tourisme ce
n'est pas que du musée c'est aussi la
nature avec le vexin avec la vallée de
chevreuse donc je pense qu'on peut
développer beaucoup plus l'activité
touristique estivale pourrait connaître
une très belle arrière saison les
perspectives d'un mois de septembre
ensoleillé à pourrait encore booster les
chiffres selon 71 % à des professionnels
du tourisme c'est en sera bon voire très
bon grégory qui on regardera cela avec
attention merci michael pour cette
chronique